-Kelly and John,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you've got.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Breakfree" by Ariana Grande.
-There's a lot of Ariana today.
-You have to decide who's gonna
sing this one.
-Miss Clarkson?
-I -- okay. I -- okay.
I know this one, but not as well
as some of the others! Okay.
-Oh, that's why --
it's what makes the game fun.
-Okay, okay. Oh, my God.
-Okay, here we go.
-This is already not fair, she
knows every song on the planet!
-No I don't! That's not!
-Water!
-No.
-No, No f--
-Everyone stay!
Just everyone stay
in their boxes!
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Sighs ]
-Alright, Kelly,
whenever you're ready.
-Wait, is it ♪ Take it ♪
what -- how's it gonna happen?
-[ Indistinct speech ]
-Oh, yeah.
[ Intro to "Breakfree"
by Ariana Grande plays ]
-♪ I don't wanna
hear you lie tonight ♪
Now that I've become
who I really am
♪ This is
the part when ♪
♪ I say I don't want ya ♪
-♪ Ay-yi-yi-yi-yi ♪
Yeah. I know, I know.
-♪ I'm stronger ♪
♪ Than I've been before ♪
-Sing!
-♪ This is the part
when I break free ♪
♪ Now that I pick ♪ --
Oh, no! [ Shrieks ]
[ Laughter ]
-You have to sing.
-Oh, that's fun.
That's a lot of water.
-Yeah.
-Doesn't rhyme!
-[ Laughs ]
-That last line doesn't rhyme!
-Doesn't rhyme.
-How are you supposed to
remember what it says?
-Alright that is fantastic.
Can we see that again
in slow motion please?
I have to see that again,
please?
-[ Slow-motion scream ]
Alright, 50,000 points for
Ariana and Blake right there.
-Doesn't rhyme!
-Okay.
Ariana and Blake,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song
you guys get.
-Oh, God, help.
Help me.
Oh, I can do this!
-"Stronger" by Kelly Clarkson.
It's a great song.
Wow.
It's a bummer that you didn't
get that, Kelly.
-I can do this.
-I feel like "Stronger"
is a more well-known song.
-Who's gonna sing it?
-Oh, Ariana.
-I'll do it, I'll do it.
-Alright, Ariana's gonna sing
this one. Okay. Here we go.
"Stronger" by Kelly Clarkson,
whenever you're ready.
-I just wanna point out that,
like, her most famous songs
we did not go with
and mine you did.
-I get it I understand.
Here we go.
-[ Gasps ]
Okay, I got this one.
♪ What doesn't kill you
makes you stronger ♪
♪ Stand a little taller ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I'm lonely
when I'm alone ♪
♪ What doesn't kill you makes a
fighter ♪
♪ Footsteps even lighter ♪
♪ Over 'cause you're gone ♪
♪ What doesn't kill you
makes you stronger ♪
♪ Stronger ♪
Nope. I don't know.
-No, no, no, no, no!
-[ Kelly screams ]
-When is it?
-Spray her. Spray her!
-[ Shrieks ]
-Can we see that again
in slow motion,
just 'cause it's worth it,
why not?
-[ Slow motion ]
When does -- [ Shrieks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is 50,000 points
for Kelly and John.
-[ Cheers ]
-50,000? 50,000?
-[ Laughs ]
-For this last song,
all four of you are going to
take turns singing, so pay
attention to your screens.
You'll switch off line by line.
When the music stops,
you'll have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get sprayed.
And this round is worth
200,000 points.
So whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Let's see
what our final song is.
[ Warbles ]
-Oh, this is a good one.
-"Shake it Off" by Taylor Swift.
-We'll see how things go when I
think I know it.
-[ Scoffs ]
You better or I'm leaving.
-We got this. We got this.
-How does this go?
Shake it, shake it off.
-Alright, Kelly, you're gonna
start us off here, okay?
-♪ I don't run away ♪
-Whenever you guys are ready,
Kelly, please begin.
[ Intro to "Shake it Off"
by Taylor Swift plays ]
♪♪
-♪ I stay out too late ♪
-Yes, Ariana.
-♪ Got nothing in my brain ♪
-Yes, John!
-♪ That's what people say,
mm, mm ♪
♪ That's what people say,
-Blake!
-♪ I go on too many dates ♪
-♪ But I can't make 'em stay ♪
-♪ At least that's what
people say, mm, mm ♪
♪ That's what
-John.
-♪ But I keep cruising can't
stop, won't stop moving ♪
-Blake!
-♪ I got this music in mind ♪
♪ It's gonna be alright ♪
-♪ It's gonna be alright ♪
-That's right. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ 'Cause the players gonna
play, play, play, play, play ♪
-[ Indistinct singing ]
-♪ I'm just gonna shake, shake,
shake, shake, shake ♪
♪ I shake it off, I shake it
off, whoo-hoo-hoo ♪
-♪ Heartbreakers gonna go break,
break, break, break ♪
-♪ Break, break, break, break ♪
-Whoo! No!
Aah! No!
Blake!
-[ Slow motion ]
♪ Break, break ♪
-[ Slow motion ] Aah! No!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We won!
-Yeah!
-That means you are the winners!
Get out here!
Kelly, Kelly, that's for you!
John, that's for you.
You are the winners!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winners of that,
ladies and gentlemen.
I'm so sorry.
-[Mouths ] It's okay.
-I'm so sorry you got wet.
Thank you, guys, for playing.
Thank you so much for playing.
I appreciate that.
Not bad.
-Hey. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait.
-Winner.
-You gotta take the loss
right there, buddy.
-I'm taking the loss.
I'm taking the loss.
We lost. We lost.
-Yeah.
-Have you been in this?
-Have you ever done this as the
host of the show?
Have you ever been in --
Here, come here.
I'll show you what it's like.
-I don't have to do this.
-See what it's like,
-I don't have to do it!
-Just see what it's like,
come on. Come on.
Come on. Jimmy. Yeah!
Come on, man!
[ Audience chanting "Jimmy" ]
This is your show!
This is a great opportunity
for you, Jimmy!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Let's see what you're made of.
Yeah!
-Alright. That's good.
Alright. That's enough!
Thank you!
-Thank you all for playing.
And thank you all for watching!
We'll see you next time
on "That's my Jam"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!